welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe that it's important to say thank
you to the people in your life who've
had an impact the people who've helped
you grow your business because you can't
do this alone you need people to help
you and it's nice to every now and then
just say
thank you so today i want to thank jason
liu and i just came back from
my trip to asia and i stayed in a couple
places and and when i travel i don't
like just staying in the big box hotel
chains because a marriott is great but
i'm married as a merit as a marriage as
a marriage and i wanted to stay at a
place that's more local so a service i
love using is called airbnb and what it
does is connect travelers like me with
people who want to rent out their homes
and so you get a much more local
authentic feel which is what i was after
when i traveled and on this trip i
stayed at two different
places with airbnb the first was in hong
kong and the second was in beijing now
when you sign up for airbnb what you're
paying for is a room right typically
what happens is you get instructions for
how to find the apartment or the house
it gives you instructions on there's
usually like a lock box on the door and
you enter in a code and you have the key
and then it's a nice you know clean room
and you put the key back in when you're
done and you go home that's the process
typically and in the place i had in hong
kong that's exactly what it was i got
exactly what i paid for when i went to
beijing though that's where i met jason
and this guy goes way above and beyond
and really made our trip special so
first of all so what did jason do first
of all he messaged us and said hey when
you come
send me a text because i'll meet you at
this popular street corner and take you
to the apartment i don't know if you've
been to beijing before but it's it's
packed right it's 20 million people one
of the biggest cities in the world
finding your way around can be tough and
so he met us on a popular street corner
and and guided us to how to find his
apartment so it's a smooth
entrance right so we know how to get
there it's a good feeling right from the
start he toured us around his place he
showed us how all the different gadgets
and gizmos worked he had this machine
that helped purify the air and he had
this japanese toilet seat that did all
sorts of
crazy stuff the fun to experiment with
anyway we won't get into that but he
showed us around he showed us how
everything worked and made sure if we
had any questions he was there let him
know you know here's here's his phone
number
and it was just a great
welcoming to the city
we opened up the fridge and he had some
egg rolls in there for us he had some
candies in there for us if we got
snack-ish we could we could peck on it
and then he started telling us
recommendations for where to have
breakfast and where to have dinner and
where to have lunch and things to see
when it was a heavily polluted day he he
wrote to us and said hey if you're going
outside today make sure you go out and
buy the masks and for us like i'd never
worn a mask out in public and you know
he said okay go to go to this store
make sure you buy this grade of mass
because there's all kinds and and and we
did and we paid attention to it because
it was it was really really bad
pollution
and when we were leaving he said you
know i'm going to meet you again uh
let's meet at the at the condo at this
time and he met us and he thanked us and
he asked how everything was he hailed a
cab for us and told the driver where to
go and so
you know
the dude just went way over and above
what was expected we got way more than
just a room that's what i expected right
a clean room and and he helped make our
vacation
special and so that's what you need to
do as an entrepreneur right you don't
just offer the bare basics
because that's boring because it doesn't
inspire referrals it doesn't inspire
repeat business if i'm going back to
beijing i'm going to go see jason and
use his place if my friends are going to
beijing i'm going to say hey you have to
go stay with jason he's the best guy to
stay with and so
you got to do that guys you gotta go way
above and beyond and over deliver like
crazy to get repeat business and get
more froze so
anyway jason
thank you so much you helped make our
trip special really from the bottom of
our hearts uh
i can't thank you enough for
for how awesome you were man it really
helped make our trip i appreciate it um
and for those of you watching
take time today to thank somebody who
has helped you in your business in your
life you know you can't do this alone
take five minutes
you can make a video you can write an
email you can write a handwritten note
and it doesn't have to cost you anything
just a couple minutes of your day to
show some appreciation to show some
gratitude and say
thank you
believe
for those who watching you like the
video you want to see more just like
this you can subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon
you